life is simple in the village of Newtok
Alaska surrounded by water and the
Arctic tundra the 350 you pick natives
who live here hunt their own food and
take care of each other the best they
can but when someone sick help is much
further away that doctors are worried
that my right time like cope blanket
Albertina Charles is a schoolteacher to
get to an eye doctor she'll have to
leave Newtok by plane
she makes the journey every other month
at a cost of thousands of dollars the
Alaskan government's Medicaid program
pays for the transportation even though
I work even though I earn money I have
kids I have kids I carry money more than
1/3 of new togs residents live in
poverty in a state that's been an
economic recession since 2015 Alaska's
governor slashed the Medicaid budget
last summer
eliminating non-emergency adult dental
care and cutting payments to specialists
and travel providers by 5% that's led to
fears of doctors and airlines dropping
out of the state health program which
many Alaskan Natives depend on with no
medicine if an elder or child get sick
they can die we are now in the city of
Anchorage where Albert Tina's eye
specialist doctor is found to get here
she has to take two flights to cross 800
kilometres of mountain and ice a journey
well known to many rural Alaskans well
we began yesterday morning we tried to
catch us right through you know sleek
down here but the weather was bad so
they canceled their flights Mary Epoque
will finally see a neurologist after two
days of travel I asked what she do
without the government paid flights to
the hospital tougher it's unfair to the
to penalize this group of people who do
live in a remote area by not letting
them have their you know medically
necessary
here the governor has warned more budget
cuts are to come
they'll be felt deeply here in rural
Alaska where the most vulnerable and
isolated populations are found
Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera Newtok
Alaska